no no no no no no no
that's super dangerous one fourth attack
Trident he's going the wrong way this
would be the ultimate cause Camp's game
this is the guy who was the meme of
pogchamps one right this is the guy that
lost in six moves to Charlie we all
remember it because it's been seen
millions of times and now he is one of
the better players and that's a pretty
cool thing and just in regards to the
whole POG Champs tournament Arc right
scripted
yeah uh but by the way that we do in
fact have game time uh we have a
we have a hedgehof defense xqc is
playing uh White
yep we can already we already know they
made some moves because we've got the uh
the stream delay fair play for those who
ever wonder why the look in is a little
behind that is by Design don't yell at
us because for fair play reasons
um we already know that this is on the
board and it's a symmetrical Petrov
Danny my my eval bar shows percent win
percent draw percent law is that a new
thing yeah it's a new thing as long as
so so it's a feature that as long as we
are in the opening book rather than
showing the eval because what's the
point in showing the computer's opinion
about a position that's been played five
thousand times
um we show the percentages of the game
and then the moment we go out of book
um we we change to a traditional eval
like like we have there
oh yeah it was showing me the first oh
my good that is a little sexy you like
what do you think yeah yeah Eric will be
happy now now it's now it's just showing
an equal position and the the players
are in a queenless position oh is xqc
gonna take and blunder on B2 uh oh uh oh
you called it he did take
he did take
but will he see B2
we're already in a big moment that's it
take my Pawn's out okay at least he sees
it he played Pawn to C3 oh okay that is
not a big fan of this episode I'm gonna
get my Knights out of this right okay
yeah I got I got this as well
yeah
um down the line but hey we gotta move
we gotta move chat we gotta move
good plan
oh my horse are stuck at home
for free
paper
and if you want to instant replay that
show what Papa plot did with Bishop H4
that was a bad idea going after the pawn
he he had an accuracy of 98 before he
did that like he was just playing like
Magnus Carlson and then he just went
here
hey double question mark that's why he's
2 000 at puzzles Danny because for free
and he's not wrong he is not wrong that
is oh my goodness
there you go
pop a plot off track with that bishop
move as Levy showed and there you see
our explanation in case you ever wonder
what those symbols mean double question
mark is blunder I think that's pretty
intuitive I think people see double
question mark and that doesn't look good
red means bad the one thing he was
yelling at himself about Levy which is
one area he's improved has been time
he's like chat we got a move we gotta
move overall like he's just very aware
of the clock and now he's down a minute
but
again I know he's been in an easy
bracket but I have been super impressed
with his play and and here he's getting
free rewards from Papa plot with that
Bishop you're supposed to go here and
then trade the Rooks but we'll see if
we'll see if
that's what I was saying this is a Pog
champs-able game and what I mean by that
is this is not outside of the world
where where where ex you see blunders
this away because the open file Levy we
can talk about that in a game like this
where yes you're up a night but Knights
are some of the hardest pieces for
amateurs to coordinate he owns the only
open file if he plays rookie two or
rookie three here I forget what the eval
Bar says I think this is actually way
closer than it looks okay he's not
playing it unfortunately he's helping it
he's helping yeah rookie two is a is a
very high level conceptual move just
understanding that you should be very
active with your Rooks uh yeah and Felix
will probably play Knight F3 like okay
goes forward that also makes sense
of excuse me sideways
Rock contest
wow then take
take
move
that's pretty good
wow I can't believe you saw all of that
is pretty good
Levy he's been watching videos that only
been a brilliant move for the agenda
[Music]
might have been brilliant
oh but that's a great move too B6
pushing him back
no
wait a minute honestly if you take back
Bishop H4 it's coming it's good wait
honey six Rook C8 Fork oh he sees it
this way too
it's over I win
one two trident
back to back
Bing
this game is over
his pawns are sideways baked that's so
bad that's so bad that's like chat
bad doesn't he have that two to the
center yuck
yeah
although F6 is a good move by Papa plot
yeah it was a great move
does he remember the Rook contest
that's a good move
sideways beaked
I look I haven't heard the Trident maybe
he said Trident before not Vista he said
Trident I've never heard of sideways
beaked that's I can't the things that
these streamers say is like Sensational
I I his spawns are weird very weird
Pawns
they're pretty weird they're pretty
weird
he sees the fork
see if Kevin plunders this or keeps the
game going oh he did look at that good
move oh tonight tonight
you see the night is hanging
[Music]
good game if he plays King D2
freaking development
sometimes I think he's just doing
anything about this one he's not really
thinking about it like at all
it's not about not thinking he just
doesn't have much he can move he just
take take
huh
oh back to the fork oh he's he's crazy
too
one
yeah bro
killing you three four this guy is not
the uh not the xqc we've seen in many
other product Champs do I go fancy nah
no fanciness he's on the black pieces
too so it doesn't matter
foreign
what's snacking on these sideways
are very good you think oh well you
could just take in this nah I'm good
brother
[Music]
so fast
dude he's he's on another level like
honestly like this is
Planet X let's let's hope we get a
stalemate just not just because I'm I'm
looking for some content I will back
protect my pieces
that's right
that's crazy
eat the pawn eat the pawn to guard the
horse
okay that's fine too what will he do GG
paper plate it is what it is man it is
what it is paper plate
okay
that is Sensational I need to be seven
in the Pawn's gonna got an escort and it
can't go back can't go top can't go
sideways he's gotta go yeah first of all
that's pretty good I haven't heard an
English accent from you of all the ones
you bust out regularly that's not that's
not on the top of your list no no that's
kind of a sleeper one I I don't do a
great one I just kind of I whisper it it
sounds good I mean yeah the scariest
moment for any chess player find the
stalemate for black for white
am I doing I'm not even paying attention
there's no way what am I doing there it
is he's gonna he's gonna he's gonna get
it done oh oh
yes keep checking oh he's got it King G7
Queen H6 mate
sniper yeah boom boom wow wow
done
the accuracy one won't be very good the
at the accuracy will not be very good no
problem I think it I think it will be 90
. he's so happy with himself and he
should be he gets another dumb Levy
again I know I know the strongest
players in the field have not played xuc
yet they are your snaps your Sea Dogs
maybe one from already went home in
ghastly but the dude is playing well
he's I mean it's it's how it's how he's
finishing these games too Levy I I we
have a game speaking of we did yeah we
got a game we have liftoff
pop a plot with white I'm gonna I'm
gonna guess that we've been
overestimating Felix's path to the next
round let's see what let's see what
Kevin can do with the white pieces I
think he's I think he's gonna because
again Levy you take back Bishop H4
and papa plop played great last time
honestly yep yeah he it was just one of
those mistakes where there was
absolutely nothing you could do after it
uh I don't know it was like injuring
yourself in a sport that was it that he
had no chance after that let's obvious
that's a very not good move because you
weakened your light squares forever more
but that's what happens when they face
the Italian they get nervous about
Knight G5
yeah I mean my goodness
um
F6 is definitely not a move but now
they're in a brand new territory yeah
they're in uh
they're in whatever this is they're in
the uh the langel variation of the of
the Italian opening
whatever it is you have the the
chess.com opening book
night's getting in trouble oh he sees it
oh I'm gonna die him but yeah
set it up set it up cover the Escape
score with the Knight or the queen and
then play before X will never see it
coming
yeah
a great town yeah
look at that oh
Oh that's oh that's a cheeky little move
he's not gonna see it he's gonna there's
no way the only move down for black is
Pawn to B6 no way
you didn't see it suck oh huge
this is it
ah it's already on the board he played
B4 oh Levy amazing we could have we
could have tiebreakers here pop a plot
with the white pieces
that's amazing wow yeah from the top
rope and I mean he he you know why he
got all of that he got all of that
because he took on G8 I have no evidence
of that whatsoever but the Knight has
just stopped yeah
well again this has been a bad game for
for X from the start for those who
aren't uh who uh calling it like they
see it F6 was a bad move and papa plot
is in control
yep he takes the Knight and now now he
has the same situation that xqc had but
the difference in my opinion is that
White's night Advantage here isn't as
easy to convert because the position is
so asymmetrical last game it was
completely symmetrical this game
he could do something on the B file he
could
I don't know but it's not as easy okay
that I'm not crazy about that move
though because that's making it more
symmetrical
uh those are Papa Plata's goons man
they're he's got he's taking on the
whole uh the whole Squad rookie shape by
the way on the board I predicted this I
I thought there could be some problems
here you know you got to go back
and you gotta go back what a twist
ending that would be by the way if Papa
plot takes this to Blitz Blitz Anything
Can Happen man these are these are not
professional chess players right this
isn't Hikaru Nakamura forcing things
into a blitz tiebreaker where he knows
he beats everyone
Levy this could be the end of a of a
really a really shocking POG Champs uh
campaign for xqc I love how we just went
from who is xuc playing in the final in
LA to pop up D5 is
um
that's pot chips oh he has they take C5
if okay we should probably listen to
Papa plot stream if he sees that it's
over yeah let's see that's it
let's see if Kevin finds Knight takes E5
almost okay it's not as good as 1965 but
it's almost better it shows he's using
all of his pieces seize the pin this
makes it makes it so hard to see how xqc
doesn't lose this
yeah I mean
actually you see I I can see the
reaction is probably dumbfounded at that
he's like what like I can't take the
Knight he's just put my Pawn to my Queen
that's ridiculous and he's threatening
to take the pawn
and he's down on time okay by the way he
still doesn't if he trades Queens xqc
still has a chance here because remember
he only has to draw yeah like this is
not yeah that's not a good idea don't
drink this don't do it no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
that's super dangerous
even with low time Felix has a very good
chance to draw this game now I think a
good reason to trade especially when
you're winning but in this case I would
not have done this because the attack
was more powerful than the other
Concepts you have two different concepts
clashing and one super seeds use your
knight and your queen get in here right
Danny show them how dumb that was show
him 95 like show them how quickly it's
over I mean like if he finds this move
right yeah Knight E5 either this and
then you can win the The Rook if this
you can win The Rook uh oh this there's
also a queen
and if this there's Queen E6 and I I
just assume
assume it's somewhere here I mean you
can just
um
yeah but this now you gotta find Knight
E5 check and hope for this and then two
different forks and
this is a good oh oh Rook G4 Rook G4 and
here he's got it okay
no I feel like look at Felix he he's he
didn't fall for that sorry go ahead no I
was gonna say oh but that's a great move
we'll pop up lots of play Rook F2
I love how you pointed out the competing
Concepts that is instructor for everyone
sometimes you want to trade when you're
winning but not when your opponent's
king is about to be checkmated so here
okay he does find him he does find it
Levy Papa plot converting converting
yeah we said it wasn't a great idea but
if he manages to get it done then he
will have the last laugh but does he
know the the winning kind of idea here
use the d-pawn as a battering ram get in
attack this or is he gonna get lost in
the weeds wow
wow does he take with the Knight because
it's check yes he does he does now it's
still okay for black or you know it's
losing for black but not not clear
oh totally not clear 94 you gotta find
Rook D6
like is he gonna go yeah see he he's
then there's like back rank problems
with the king is always safe that's the
good thing the king is always safe on G2
his nerves are showing
you're gonna get yourself mated I don't
even know how like he's still that's not
possible but it might happen
okay
that one's not right but that's all it's
like Sudoku it's all covered so just go
King H2 yeah
worked out
yeah I say we go listen to Felix soon
here get some get some English streaming
not that I don't love guessing what
Kevin's saying in German but yeah does
does Felix see a comeback at all there
there are ladder made comebacks there
there's uh H file made comebacks xqc is
laser focused he is laser focused right
now Danny stalemate It's Not Over
you're right it's not over oh it's mate
Ricochet was made in one oh it still
made one right now
excuses mated rookie Checkmate on the
board right now oh he's missing oh he's
winning his Rook oh
but dude it's not over as long as he's
alive there's a chance for stalemate Yep
this is like freaking heart attack
territory yeah cause the Knight is
covering some weird squares too he's
gotta like do this in a way where he's
gonna seal it yeah that's it right there
right there put it down on F1 it's a
ladder make just Rooks give
he's so nervous oh my God he's so
nervous
oh my God oh my God Danny I can't but
he's on it he's got it he's got a skater
he's ice skating the ice skater
he's done it
he has done it borderline pre-move he's
not gonna do it he's that nervous yep
oh my goodness
this is the inside of strength
excuse me to move let's see it huh bro I
thought I haven't already type bro
oh God has stars
the BM from xqc oh my god oh my god
wow he's just gonna let his time run out
oh my god well oh he doesn't want his
opponent to feel the glory of checkmate
all right that's not gonna take too
kindly to that it Blitz that could be
bad karma could be
wow all right ladies and gentlemen ions
schweiser
wow Levy we have overtime we have tie
Breakers that was absolutely wild yeah
uh and now it looks like we have a
foreign nights thing ish they're just
playing fast
they're just playing fast both players
are going to be super nervous making the
kind of Trades you don't want to make
bringing the queen out for black but
okay like you said I mean it's not
excuses for Felix because it doesn't
matter we're here in overtime but he did
have a disconnect he's got to shake it
off and focus and uh pop a plot this is
it he could send the uh the highest
viewed human on Twitch that being Felix
he could send him home
yeah the most famous chess player of all
time that's right HTC is probably the
most famous person to ever play chess
like
that's probably I don't know that's
actually a wild thing to say
because it weirdly true okay
um it could be like Messi or Ronaldo I
guess if they actually played it right
like if Messi actually played chess then
yeah it would be messy uh but we don't
know if they actually did I mean they
just took the photo and then it turned
out that it wasn't a real photo so yeah
uh Bishop D4 you got to take this you
got to take this guy you gotta take it
move your knight to safety
we got a lot of equal chests here still
nothing nothing huge for either player
pop a plot up by 20 seconds though
that's what I'm noticing
yeah
Knight takes D4 he is playing so fast
take I don't like that move I I don't
like oh I don't like that movie they're
pinning yourself was bad but taking the
night was even worse
agreed
but okay because he's gonna kill it so
good unless he push this up
yeah pushing was the better move but
this is fine it's equal
to the queen take with the queen not the
pawn
good that's what you're cheering for
push tape yeah for a second I'm cheering
for the best move to be played by both
players on every move that's my that's
what I'm cheering for we are good wait a
minute we are good we this is solid this
is solid
does he see on passo wait what
the big moment does the French Canadian
see the own pass home okay or does he
put the queen on a for free Square
botesque damn it take
shout out to Papa plot for playing so
fast by the way
do you think that's nerves or that's uh
he's just trying to assert dominance I
don't know but I don't what matters is
he's up on the clock here I should have
thought that much
he's right he shouldn't have opened up
the file Somebody's gotta free a back
rank here or someone else is going to
get mated I'm like giving me anxiety
it's like watching your kids wrestling
someone's about to get hurt someone's
about to get hurt
oh wow this is crazy he's actually gonna
push his d-pawn just invest in deep on
Industries D6 there it is somebody free
your back rank please someone is about
to hit their head on the couch kids are
wrestling please for your back range I'm
freaking out as a chest Dad I'll put the
rook in front of the pawn first and then
do it
oh Danny it's gonna be like Rook d8
rookie one and then it's just gonna be a
mate it's gonna be a backbreak mate on
E8 that decides POG Champs in this match
yep
time even by the way we're back to even
yep a minute five each buck 50.
oh that's a good move wow that is a good
move centralize the queen for white Rook
D1 or queen D5 don't go there don't go
there because there's no mate there's no
mate at the end there's Queen f8 and and
he accidentally no now it's takes takes
and he's not getting mated Danny he's
gonna he's gonna miss it and then he's
gonna block
oh my God possible checkmates
oh my God he's seeing the wrong way he's
singing the wrong way don't do it
don't do it
oh no okay now we got some Pantry Queens
don't trade Queens he can't trade Queens
if xqc trades Queens he might not even
make it out of the quarterfinals oh no
this is Nazis losing it's just math
just math it's six pawns versus five
bring their kings up and black is
completely winning
don't no
no A4
A4 is winning Pawn takes pawn and A4 and
it's just a square you're outside of the
square oh God
okay and they're
I was just gonna say Danny and even if
you do take the pawn is a decoy and your
King has to go take White's pawns but do
they know all of that
I'm I'm having anxiety just watching
this Kingdom Pawn ending again what is
going on here
now Papa Plata has to clutch at Danny he
has to completely forget about his Pawn
here and he has to go King E6 King F5
which which you can do you can do he's
smart enough to go he's gonna go get
this Pawn I'm gonna go get this Pawn
yeah but
yeah ah we'll go check it out we'll go
check it out
what what no no he has to bring his King
he's got to stop using his pawns oh my
God no no no no don't play your pawn
move
oh wait he already did it we saw him he
did he did he did he did he did he has
to bring his King he has to bring his
King
oh oh no no put the pawn down
always sees it oh my God he's gonna do
it he's gonna bring his King to the base
of White's Pawn chain and he's gonna
just bring what no
[Laughter]
oh no that was the one move that draws
oh God he couldn't make up his mind now
excuse he's getting back in time to stop
White's King from infiltrating
you could lose this with black because
you just because clearly he's really
nervous so he he might like overextend
any and then he'll he get he's gonna get
himself into which is a German word and
then he's gonna lose both of his pawns
oh my God he actually irony the irony of
Papa plot loses by zug's Wong oh the
irony by the way
Danny this is this is losable for for
everybody involved but now it's like
King E5 oh my God oh my God Danny oh my
God going the wrong way he's going the
wrong way this would be the ultimate
cause Champs game okay no okay no now
we're getting a trade xqc
dude they're both going the wrong way
they're both going they should have went
up and and yes this is still a draw oh
oh Levy if okay never mind if if it's a
trade on G3 there was a chance the papa
pluck could still win by getting the
opposition yeah King H3 oh my God
dude
this is still a draw everyone this is
still a draw but we're literally walking
backward
oh my God
oh my God that xqc's freaking out he's
like what all right let's go listen to
xqc see if he figures out that he might
have a winning chance let's do it
stalemate Stevens
more chests around the corner XGC is
still alive in POG Champs in shocking
fashion Papa plot had this game
unbelievable wow official draw
yeah
Wild
XTC is about to find out that he
actually got lucky
look at that look at that throw look at
that black is totally winning in the
middle of that game Arc and then it goes
the other way back to a draw we are tied
at one and a half games a piece
um I'll double overtime let's let's
double overtime we already had this with
Frank and gasly this is the this is the
year of double overtime in pod Champs
apparently here we go we're back to the
Italian if xqc plays this same blunder
of F6 we are in trouble
we are in trouble if we're if we're xqc
fans F6 is a bad move he already played
it once and papa plot took him to the
cleaners
yeah oh night she oh I I didn't know if
if they if they knew about uh if they
knew about the fried liver but he looked
it up he looked it up maybe in the break
who knows and now he's no longer played
this bad F6 move
yeah this is definitely an improvement
uh and now castles D3 Bishop G5 is good
good beginner chess on display I would
say this is early intermediate chess for
sure by both sides I mean that end game
hold was really good high level uh high
level chess here
we knew this was going to be a good
match maybe not this good xqc's got an
itch scratching it scratching it himself
you know it's always using the festival
yeah what is X thinking about he's got
oh no that's not the right move
suck suck that is definitely not the
right whoa
Yep this is good for white now that's a
good move too I mean even if it lets
black take C3 that's a nice pin that's a
nice pin hey you it's a nice pit over
here
all right let's remind everybody real
quick we are in tie breaks we are in tie
breaks right now which means we're in
Blitz we're actually in double tie
breaks if you're just tuning in Where
Have You Been we got Blitz if we're
still tied we're gonna keep rinson
repeating but we still have four more
matches today Levy I just want to tell
everybody because we've got a lot of
viewers the day has only just begun
after this matchup I think we go right
to do we go right to cutie Cinderella
and Jenny or who goes up first who's
next oh saikuno I'm sorry I don't re I
don't read the names that are in front
of my face I'm the anti one burgundy but
but I like it I I like the name Sky Kuno
in fact
yeah if we interview him I'm going to
ask him if he wants to be Sky Kuno and
yeah that that is a mismatch poor
saikuno yeah
also there's a fork on E2 Levy highlight
it just so that just so the boys and
girl there we go that's uh that's a
problem
oh oh it takes them this
I'll put there's Knight D4 and that ends
the game that just ends the game because
White's king is too open
yeah
all right maybe let's let's go check out
Felix let's go see what he's talking
about if he sees Knight D4 we could be
over we could be heading home
he doesn't see it he's not he doesn't
see it Levy
nevermind oh spoke to you soon
um it looks like he does see it now I
think I think that's better
what else is there oh man what am I
doing that's a move it's down on the
clock though this isn't over
oh my God yes I take the pawn
okay oh he gives the part with check no
oh no oh King H1
we know for his game over Queen f4's
mate queen of four is oh my God his
thirds in seconds
Levy hold me I know you can't but I'm
nervous I'm so nervous you gotta move
the king out of the corner he has 40
seconds he has to move his Queen out of
wow wow
D juicer
certified
juicer
plate eliminated
holy
wow wow
I don't know if Felix knows how much he
got away with one there but he was he
his back was literally against the wall
ladies and gentlemen should have gone
home in the last game
holds on and somehow is still surviving
in pogchamps five
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you